um so you would say like that the
difference between you now and maybe a
couple years ago was like do you think
like you weren't maybe taking your craft
seriously yeah no i wouldn't because
[ __ ] like if i was taking a crab
serious back then like we we would have
had way more classic [ __ ] like you feel
me i would have been more of an aspect
to the situation i was a good aspect to
the situation but i'd have been a bigger
aspect if i was taking the most serious
like yeah i was good but i went great
like you feel me like i'm in the process
of becoming great right now is there old
sob [ __ ] that you hear yourself on
you're like man that [ __ ] was wack like
[ __ ] i wish all the time
what's your least favorite verse
and a lot of them a lot of them yeah
i got i got some good ones off the show
no no for sure but i just feel like oh
so there's a lot of [ __ ] out there
to me that's fair i mean it's also dope
to admit you know a lot of people would
admit such things you know what i'm
saying yeah i'm my biggest critic like
i go to this day like i could go in the
studio someone come out be like this
[ __ ] we like go to the next one like you
feel me so if i make some weak [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] is gonna make me wanna do is
just make something better like you
feeling me
i'm my biggest critic though for sure
like i ain't scared to
save my [ __ ] weak like
i ain't putting that [ __ ] out if i think
it's weak too like it's hella songs and
they can make that you feel me that
we'll never hear yeah it will never hear
that's fair i can keep the quality
coming off a show